welcome to disk on a shine yes pretty
who knows seperti and wants to
participate please applaud
alright so will you know stepper d times
up we prepared a few little things
that's very cute it seems like it's not
a thing here in Asia really but it's a
really fun game show where contestants
need to find the right question to an
answer they can win prizes today
reaction actually have some here I this
is an ipad pro hope that that's gotta be
the first place and i don't want to make
it go away right away so that's one
place we have a few others like folks
and other good things and we have three
volunteers that were so kind to
participate in play with us now the game
is actually rather hard some of the
questions might not be easy and they
might not know them because they had
literally no time to prepare for this
the audience therefore needs to help so
you can shout in if you know an answer
but only before you see somebody hitting
a button then you need to shut up ok
button pressed you see this on the
screen later you shut up before that you
shout right or you say the answer if you
know it great some of the questions they
might know themselves and they can
answer themselves so let's meet today's
contestants we have applause please we
have elson lee develops front and two
eyes and wants to be the weapon much
more usable place from bangalore please
welcome Prince iya she build scalable
back end solutions in no chair and
originally from Indonesia but now
working in Malaysia we have Albert
please applause for Albert
alright so please get to your buttons
audience are you ready this is our
playing field and we have a few
categories if you have seen jeopardy you
will be very familiar with this the
first category is if yes 2015 plus the
second category and this is a pun in
case you don't get it Internet Explorer
the third category tools and frameworks
the fourth category j/s conf appropriate
I think the fifth one cats I hope the
audience knows a lot about that one and
the last one singapore that's where you
all are actually I checked we have
people from with 43 different
nationalities here today applause for
your audience and now we do one test
question you can win already but like we
just gonna see how that goes because I
gonna pick the question after that the
speaker that winds will pick the
question so you want to have your hands
on the buzzer and we're gonna start and
we gonna start with hmm let's see what
internet explorer has to offer internet
explorer 200 tables with specifically
crafted images in the corner cells were
frequent substitution for the lack of
this popular CSS property in ie8
audience and players what could be the
question to this answer shout audience
if you know how louder until they're
pressed and know the answer ah there we
go francia you can make the sound a bit
louder so the audience hears it and can
actually stop shouting water ladies you
need to formulate it as a question what
is a water spot a lady that is correct
what is border radius
there we go petir won its first two
hundred dollars and now you get the gist
of the game now you shout louder you
shout more often until these guys feel
self-confident enough to actually press
the button alright francia you can
choose the next category yes 2015 4 200
200 it is the alternative name of this
category that more than eighty percent
of developers still use according to
recent polls you chose the category just
now Alton Java scream not really weighs
javis free YT x 60 that is correct very
good very good alright you can choose
the next I'll choose to San framework
sacre one the second yes released in
2006 it's the one framework that heavily
popularized JavaScript over the next
year's an estimated over vice jquery
very good very good $400 forward okay
you choose the next question okay i'll
choose caps number six for six hundred i
ask Simon
they're increasingly popular social
hanger-on what is gas goofy corrects cat
cafes you choose the next one yes 2015
um 300 300 it provides syntactic sugar
for the construction of strings it works
similar to the string interpolation
feature in Prolog Python everything
where's the interpolation what is this
Parisian interpolation 03 the other two
why is back tix I'd should know Francie
yeah you know our what is templates I
had the closest it's a closest what is
template literal very good she's the
next category 0 GS gone and 101 army
yeah I'm not sure what's up question ok
these the mascot and holds the name of
the place providing hot and caffeinated
beverage to this event Albert why is
Jimmy monkey that is correct next I'll
choose singapore number three janet this
almost seven billion dollar development
built and reclaimed on built it has
helped yeah god elson ways ways risotto
sentosa enough now it's easy yeah wait
oh you're not anymore i know okay uh
where is martini depressed first oh
where is marina bay sands that is
correct
nice you can choose the other one all
right i'll choose to send framework for
hunger scope management becomes the most
complex enough when maintaining Albert
what is angular yes that is correct all
right next ah I love capsule I'll choose
caps number 800 cafero father I'd say is
Camtasia last year he talked about dots
and his blond hair and beard give him a
line like look he loves cats you know
who is Pat Scott yeah Oh who's Pat Scott
no audience clearer louder Albert who is
Matt sharjah okay win oh thank you I
should have put a picture here so that
you even know that all right you choose
the next I'll choose GS cotton 400 check
on 400 he started jazz confidently 2008
together with his wife in the US and
almost had to cancel the event who is
Chris video that is correct all right
next one you can choose Elton es2015
mm-hmm 800 800 nice it's a function
which can be a belated touted what our
generators you barely read that what is
it generator
okay oh yes 2015 600 sushi remains
technical here unlike traditional
functions this function shorted makes
the same length of this Prince Ian wow
what does adil that is correct okay oh
yes 2015 400 it's the first class
representation of a value that may be
made available in the future and is a
tool for a synchronous program what is
promised now she's on a roll laughing
all right okay edge slaughter 800 all
right this alternative rendering
technique is used by a year for the sake
of maintaining backward compatibility
instead of so strictly Albert what is
coffeescript now the other two what is
quarks morden that is correct oh ok our
internet explorer 600 I a 5.5 already
shipped a very complete API trying to
push modular and reusable code pieces to
build websites in your browser similar
to this proposed standard that's a tough
one does the audience know I eat 5.5
it's about back right oh wow nobody else
in where's I for you know right modular
and reusable pieces maybe think about
the standard that does this today or
wants to I heard it from the audience
robert bly slept components that is
correct thank you
all right i'll choose es con 300 300
they are low called a local talent
kindly avoiding this event with this
internet connectivity Prince Ian all
right right right i heerd it already you
can't shout anymore after somebody
pressed the other two Alison ways my
republic correct awesome stuff take the
next one I have cats 100 cats 100 it's
used by our filling companions to
control their body roll in direction
during jumps Albert Weiss caps licks
save it again cat well how many cap how
many legs does cat have no not the legs
but body parts is a good direction the
other two are you wait queue second what
is Q what is it cat's tail that's
correct I thought that was an easy run
okay Kent's or maybe not singapore
hundred singapore 800 now you want to
make it up this is the way to order
local coffee with less sugar Allison
suit I wasted I know what is Kofi see
you die is the only local on Dubois it's
a nice well done yes 205 100 all right
now he's getting cautious decisis roles
as for Mozilla CEO and CTO he's the
creator of JavaScript come on guys
robert who is bread like no almost see
us Brendan Eich correct is a block there
too great just a few months ago okay um
tools and frameworks 800 he popularized
the data format Jason and Tuvalu areas
just who is Douglas Crockford that is
correct and at this point he was
actually here two weeks ago and I want
to just show it give you a little hint
of his talk which was phenomenal now I
am about done with JavaScript um you
know it it should not have become as
important as it did and the fact that it
did is at least partly my fault sorry
alright so you two snakes internet it's
not all four hundred this is the name of
the web real-time communications API
only Microsoft edge implemented so far
everything poinciana party see that is
correct oh I think next tools and
frameworks six hundred thousand thousand
six hundred it is often compared with
more complete frameworks such as angular
or ember although its focus to young
Albert what is react that is correct you
pick next hey Jess con 200 whoa again
and it is a brutal Bavaria Germany bit
yes all right I should happen
all right you get free ones outside in
the fridge by the way all right you pick
next I'll pig singapore 200 governing
singapore for almost three decades he is
recognized as the founding father Nelson
we sleep on you that is correct okay
that seems to be a strong hold the right
category Kent 400 they are said to be
the only thing preventing a cat falling
back on its feet when slept on its back
yeah cat dos say that again oh what a
cat dos butter toast is actually correct
nice that was fast you pick next Jules
inflamed walks are 300 hammock it was
built as a result of the frustrations
over working with comments yes and with
inspiration from similar projects yes
Albert uh why is md second Weiss emd
Rick idea no from a similar project like
care or Sipan and other languages mmm
it's very popular friends yeah what does
NPM that's correct thank you know okay
Jess conf 800 it is the latest addition
to the jas kana family of events and
kicked off successfully in May this year
in Europe let's see ya o.o what is Jesus
gone from Budapest there you go
and the next one GS gone 600 Jess come
600 she's going on a winning streak here
it's the name of the first iteration of
this conference before it was granted
the naming rights to the edge is conf in
2013 this here what is gia scam that is
Craig cats 300 her gray blue eyes have
frowned on many and made her owner a
millionaire Albert Weiss grumpy cat
correct Internet Explorer 300 all right
it is the name of the rendering engine
that was first introduced with the
release of Internet Explorer version 4
in October 97 and was only just recently
replaced with the new edge browser
Robert why is trying that is correct
making the game a little bit more
interesting again to san fran walk 100
okay you want to go for the big numbers
that pony has popularized this design
pattern on the client site in 2010
francia what is MVC that is great big
next and sting op were 600 yeah after
that she has essentially one once known
as this I'll be liking event or silence
I centers like that is correct sing up
for 100 well this is not the way to win
introduced as the logo of the Tourism
Board in 64 this is a great animal how
it ah what is crap Ryan oh no no Marion
house in some ways malaya that is
correct
okay single for four hundred go for it
okay sing over 400 singapore Prime
Minister's recently released his see
version of this program yes why is su
doku doku low-sulfur that's correct if
you didn't know our prime minister has
too much time coatsy sometimes and
actually released the source code of a
sudoku solver on his facebook why not
the last two just for completeness caps
cats 200 it is the ultimate plan of all
cats and the main reason our furry
friends created the internet other you
want to rule the work kind of what is
world of images alright and the last one
it's the new ie6 please what's up okay
maybe I'm a bit more old school I'll
grind your Safari too but I was looking
for I a nice alright thank you so much
for playing this is the empty board
pretty young thang congratulations you
won myself and iPad pro there you go
that's it so number two Albert's you get
a good bunch of books look at this oh so
we have one one of my favorites actually
it's if Hemingway wrote JavaScript
Langer scroll it's a very artistic book
actually another good one CSS secrets
from Leah biru just an amazing book and
in case you want to start something with
Hardware make JavaScript robotics there
you go and elson for participating you
get a shirt
actually two shirts and one of them is
quite interesting it's a I don't know if
you can see this but it's a like
Microsoft shirt and it has a no well
with a fox on top holding a flag that's
poking up bacon it's amazing thank you
to the contestants I think that was
really fun